it's crazy that we haven't had a
live-action Star Wars show yet but in
2019 it's finally happening it's been a
long time coming but we have a little
bit of information about the very first
live-action Star Wars series the
Mandalorian and we can't wait to share
it with you
a frontier far far away they say the
Star Wars universe has room for an
infinite number of stories and now we
know what this particular story is kind
of in October 2018 a series creator and
writer Jon Favreau made a post on
Instagram laying out the basics
according to Favreau the new Star Wars
show will focus on the travails of a
lone gunfighter and the outer reaches of
the galaxy far from the authority of the
New Republic the lone gunfighter phrase
is telling making it sound like the
Mandalorian will be a space flavor take
on the western genre treating outer
space like the lawless expanse that it
is point is it's just us out here
Star Wars already owes a debt to
westerns the story goes that George
Lucas screen Sergio Leone's Once Upon a
Time in the West for the Star Wars crew
before filming and that's an easy story
to believe the original Star Wars
trilogy is full of nods to classic
Westerns heck star wars sound editors
reportedly even gave Boba Fett the sound
of spurs jangling when he walks
it looks like the Mandalorian will lean
into the genre tera manda watts in Star
Wars lore Mandalorians are fierce
warriors of a long proud and
surprisingly complex history you may not
have seen them before but you're
probably familiar with the most iconic
outfits Boba Fett wears Mandalorian
armor as did his father the Bounty
Hunter Jango Fett despite their fashion
sense they aren't Mandalorians
themselves Mandalore has never played a
role in the movies and you won't ever
actually hear the word Mandalorian in
the original trilogy but the society
nurse struggles are a big part of Star
Wars different animated series in the
Clone Wars Mandalore is a place ravaged
by centuries of war with the chaos being
severe enough to provide an opening for
none other than Darth Maul to conquer
the planet naturally he uses it as a
headquarters for his criminal syndicates
Sabine Rand one of the main characters
on Star Wars rebels is also a
Mandalorian one who plays an important
part in quoting the society's warring
ways edge of the world during an
interview at the premiere of solo Jon
Favreau and
Hadden explains when the mandalorian is
supposed to take place and the time
period sounds full of opportunity
Favreau explained that the mandalorian
takes place about seven years after
Return of the Jedi or roughly two
decades before the force awakens by this
points the Rebel Alliance has
transformed into the New Republic while
the former Imperials had eventually
formed the first order are still licking
their wounds and the galaxy's Unknown
Regions the Mandalorian is purported to
have a remote setting taking place far
away from the New Republic so it would
be surprised to see any characters from
the movies show up when the Mandalorian
takes place Luke would be busy scouring
the galaxy for for sensitive artifacts
and old Jedi knowledge poe would still
be a kid Finn would be an infant and Rey
wouldn't have even been born yet
one big rebels connection jon favreau is
an adapting Star Wars to the small
screen on his own mission under the
Ironman director is also getting a hand
from a creator some fans will recognize
Dave Filoni he may not be a household
name but if you're a modern-day Star
Wars fan you probably know his work
bologna directed the Clone Wars feature
film which let's face it isn't really
something to brag about
but he also worked side-by-side with
George Lucas to bring the subsequent
superior animated series to the air
fellow knee also co-created both rebels
and the newest Star Wars cartoon
resistance in other words he's the guy
behind a lot of the best parts modern
Star Wars Canon according to the art of
Star Wars the Clone Wars felonious the
brains behind Anakin Skywalker's beloved
apprentice ahsoka tano on rebels for
lonely and his staff raised questions
about the Jedi's relationship with the
force years before the last Jedi he even
voiced chopper rebels scene-stealing
droid
now felonious take on Star Wars - the
Mandalorian sir
he's one of the show's executive
producers and he'll make his live-action
directing debut by helming the
Mandalorians very first episode
the other big rebels connection we're
about to get into spoiler territory if
you haven't seen the series finale of
Star Wars rebels yet you may want to
check out for this part
while the Mandalorian has a title a
premise and the setting in time it still
doesn't have a cast at least not one
that's been announced but we do have
some ideas shortly after the series was
announced a theory emerged that the
mysterious lead character of the
Mandalorian is none other than the
demolitions expert on Star Wars rebel
star Sabine Wren the series ends of
Sabine in ahsoka on a quest to find
throne and
after the fall of the Empire the sort of
mission that could conceivably take
somebody to the very edge of known space
Sabine's got the right ancestry too and
it does seem curious that we haven't
seen our hero's face yet throw in
felonious involvement and the fact that
hey that really could be a woman in
there and you've got a decent argument
that Sabine is the mandalorian of the
series title maybe as a longshot but
what's in store will be exciting to
watch unfold either way we'll find out
more when the series touches down in
2019